[Music]
whereabouts in australia you from
melbourne melbourne so you weren't
affected by the flooding were you
is that why you've sat so high up
i i'm here with my family we're
traveling
in australia this is too high
and it's it's a jail
it's a jail you all you're prisoners and
you don't like to talk about it you're
sensitive about it you want to forget
the past and move on into the future
like every country that has a suspect
past
you know it's a totally inhospitable
place you shouldn't be here
at the sun you live about three quarters
of a mile from it and um
i've seen insects walking around with
knee pads
you fling yourselves into the sea when
you're not actually walking around
audibly crackling in the heat and
the sea is full of jellyfish and sharks
and other things who hate you but you
persist in living here
so we flew here you know
and with the children and everything who
are pressing the buttons and not
sleeping and
actually getting energy from the hatred
as they inspire in you on the plane
but you all really come from from irish
prisoners and and that was because the
english sent you here
a long long time ago and um the english
were very good at that you know what
founding colonies and so on a lot of it
was because of the voice
the english voice irish people you never
see starting a colony
you know willingly because irish people
wouldn't turn up they would
say we go over there it's got loads of
stuff are you coming i will yeah i've
just got to meet my brother for a quick
drink and do it i have to pick up some
knitting and think i'll be the no
but the english were very good at it
because they have that voice you know
where they can go anywhere in the world
they go to africa say and they say
what's your name hello hello i'm fubu
hello how are you hello hello
uh listen um fubu fubi i've got some
beads here in my pocket would you like
to see them would you would you like to
listen clicky clacky sound they make
aren't they pretty
you keep those you have those you enjoy
those walk away
they're yours i'll just have from where
you're standing to the horizon
thank you very much they were all very
good at that
but anyway so it's a you know it's a
jail
you live in it's lovely you've done
wonderful things with it
but you are all still in denial the only
real
reason i came i don't want to see urulu
or whirlwind
or any of your other garden phase
exhibits
the only real reason i came here is to
kill killer wiggle
[Music]
[Applause]
wild [ __ ] country i just learned what
the aboriginal was that's cool
for the last week i've been walking
around like man black people out here
love
picnics dawg what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] black people love picnicking
bro
every time i see black people they're
[ __ ] picnicking
literally every time on the grass pick
and pick the picnic
black people in america do not [ __ ] with
fields they got ptsd from that [ __ ]
that's
there's a sordid history with fields
you see a black dude on grass back home
he was being tackled
by a football player of the police but
either way
dude i couldn't believe it and finally
supposed to start explaining to me like
no they're not black with their
aboriginals and like
we got like a real you know shitty past
with them it's been very hard to get
them to assimilate to like white western
culture
and i'm like what
they're relaxing in a park drinking wine
mission accomplished australia
how white do you want them to be give
them some [ __ ] cheese and crackers
they're french
it's just crazy man i know you're not
supposed to talk about them so whatever
i won't talk
that's it no more no more aboriginal
jokes
we went to a strip club out here i saw a
stripper with [ __ ] hair that [ __ ] was
crazy
i was like seeing a beeper again i was
like what
throwback thursday holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] hair [ __ ] dude she had this
thick patch of [ __ ] hair it was like a
thick mat of there were two aboriginals
sitting on it bro it was crap
[Applause]
no [ __ ] i traded her a dance for
some goon wine
i once had sex with an australian girl
she said mid-coitus
whilst [ __ ] she said have you slimed
yet
have you slimed yet i thought it's not
[ __ ] ghostbusters
box jellyfish crocodiles snakes blue
ring octopus
red black spiders funnel web spiders
great white sharks
just some of the reasons that put me off
going to australia
every creature is bigger and angrier
than anywhere else in the world
i put it down to two things one it could
either be because spiders and snakes and
the like normally hide under rocks
the earth is one big rock australia's at
the bottom of the big rock and they're
trying to hide under it
you are a maniac just thinking about it
thinking about
where spiders go and that and that works
doesn't it no
why doesn't that work there's no real
upside down and bottom of the earth is
it it's all relative to what
it's relative to what a map that you saw
it's a coincidence
i spent three years of my life in
australia
and actual fact i didn't spend three
years i spent 18 months
but 18 months in australia it was like
three years anywhere else
and the very the australians are very
proud of the country i left
london on friday at 4 30 in the
afternoon i
flew all through friday all through
saturday or through sunday
and i arrived after 36 hours on an
airplane
i arrived and see my eyes are hanging up
and the phone says how did you find
australia
i said i got off the bloody plane and it
was there
the australians actually i know the
irish have a funny way of talking but
the australians have also
they add i.e onto a lot of words
i was there around christmas and i said
to a fellow said what are you going to
do on christmas he said well i'll think
i'll get up
chrissy die
i'll have my bracky i'll pick up the
cozy
castle watch a game of footy have a game
of drinkies and then i'll come home and
have a yummy yummy chrissy dindin
he was 64 years of age
they love the they love them in
australia they love the booze
but the beer is so cold
it's right you have to have gloves to
pick up
three beers when you look there's no
movie
everything's gotta be cold and you get a
[ __ ]
a whiner which goes into a chemist shop
and said
yeah do you have a do you have a bottle
of metallic spirits
and the camera said yes give someone he
said what's the matter don't you have a
cold one
they drink they drink i arrived there
and somebody said would you like a
schooner
i thought it was going to give me a boat
and they're always telling me always as
soon as you arrive in australia
they say watch out for the sharks
and they don't say a shark will eat you
or chew you up
they say he'll take you
you're going to be taken by a shark
and i think to myself well if he takes
me he'll die of alcoholic poisoning
and i'm swimming but in the back of my
mind
sharks i'm thinking of it i'm swimming
away and a fella goes underneath me
swims on i don't even see him and he
comes right under and he goes
with his finger
nobody's swam in that sea for about
three days
it was the nearest thing i have ever
done in my life i was across the water
on the beach
i was when i was out there i i hired
down on the coast a bungalow kind of
shack hut
which we used to go for weekends and we
always get down there
and have a few beers and swim and eat
laugh
joke and then one of these australian
friends of mine said
hey dive
[Music]
you want to be uh careful about the
grass around here
it's getting very tall and a lot of
snakes
they live in the grass you want to cut
it
and i said well i'm over here i only
come here every six weeks or something
how the hell am i going he said well buy
yourself a sheep
headroom and he laid up all the grass
so that was a very good idea i bought a
sheep for five quid
tied him up six months later he's as big
as a house
whoa everywhere somebody said you want
to get him shared
he'll dehydrate
so i go back to sydney and i go through
the yellow pages
sheep sherry unknown to me i am ringing
up the biggest
sheep-sharing company in the world
and i said i'm making inquiries about
sheep-sharing the woman said
one second please i believe you're
making inquiries about sheep sharing i
said yes
he said well let me tell you our rates
first we sheep uh
we shear sheep uh pair five thousand
ten thousand fifty thousand hundred
thousand we've got different rates we've
got peace rate we uh
we do hourly rate week we write monthly
rates
it all depends on the number of sheep
that you have percentage lost percentage
gain
how many sheep do you have i said one
he said really what's his bloody knife
mind you i'll tell you something i'll
tell you how i mean this very sincerely
the australians are perhaps one of the
most
hospitable and generous people in the
world
i mean if you're stuck for a night
they'll give you a bed
you haven't got a drink they'll give you
a drink got no money to give you money
the food they'll take the food off the
plate and give it to you
it's those white australians i don't
like